Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This month, we're looking at time management.
Now, this is a common problem for most business people,...
...how to manage time effectively.
I'd like to recommend three steps for time management.
Step 1, activity log.
This will help you understand how you're managing time presently.
Keep a log, a record of everything you're doing in your work every day.
Try this for one week.
At the end of the week, look back.
How much time are you spending on your different business activities?
Step 2, try using a task list.
Task list is when you list up all the activities or tasks you have to do.
But don't stop there.
Once that you've listed them, organize them.
One nice way to organize them is A, B, C.
Group A tasks, important and urgent.
B tasks, important but not urgent.
C tasks, not so important and not urgent.
By having a different organization,...
...this will help you understand which tasks should you spend most time on...
...and which should you do first, second, third, et cetera.
Final step, successful scheduling.
Use your activity log and your task list to understand how best to schedule your time.
A good technique here also,...
...always give yourself contingency time.
Contingency time means, kind of, emergency or backup time.
If your schedule's too tight, it's not flexible.
Something suddenly happens, you're in trouble.
So give yourselves some blocks of contingency time just in case.
So, try doing this technique today.
After you've watched this video, start making your activity log for one week,...
...then organize your task list and organize.
And finally, introduce successful scheduling...
...to help you manage time well.
Thank you and good luck!